There are a variety of
connected component methods.
The one that most people use is
referred to as row by row and
it's sort of, classic algorithm and
it's simple to go through.
And there are some efficient
speed ups that we use so,
that you can run it quickly
in industrial systems.
But, these days running your connecting
components is really the thing that's
taking your time because the machines
have gotten much faster and
the algorithm itself is pretty
straightforward row by row.
So, let's start with a picture
that looks like this.
Okay.
So, we've got 1s and 0s.
And if you look carefully.
You'll see there's really
only one object here.
Okay?
Those are all the 1s.
And what we want to do is we
want to eventually determine
that all of them should
be labeled as a 1.
Okay, but
this system doesn't know this yet.
All it knows is that there are 1s and
0s in the pixels.
All right?
So, here is the algorithm.
We start with a variable at 0 and
what happens is we go across, okay?
And when we find a new pixel, if it's
not connected to anything before it or
above it, and of course there's
no above and there's no before,
we'll increment our counter, all right?
So we start by labeling this 1 as a 1,
and then we go forward, and
then we're not connected, and
then we would get to here, and so
what would that be labeled,
what comes after 1?
2, okay.
So we label that as a 2.
So, this is going to become a 2,
all right?
And then, go over here and then what are
we going to get when we get to next one?
What are we going to label that?
3, okay?
So, that works fine.
The reason that this one is listed as
a 1 even though you've scanned it.
It's, it's connected
to the one above it.
You say, oh I'm connected so, I'm a one.
Likewise when I get over here,
likewise when I get over here,
it's connected to the one above it.
So, these are all labeled as 1,
2s and 3s.
But you see where it says here,
remember conflicts.
All right?
As I'm going through,
when I'm labeling this pixel, okay?
I now have a conflict.
because when I look behind me,
it says that I'm a 1.
And when I look above me,
it says I'm connected to a 2.
So what I do is, I pick one of those,
maybe the 1, but
I remember that I've
got a conflict there.
Likewise, I have a conflict here, and
what I learn is that 1 is the same as
2 because it's connected there, and 1 is
the same as 3, so it's connected there.
So, after I'm done labeling all of
these, and I've got 1s, 2s,and 3s,
I relabel everything as a 1 because
all the 2s get relabeled as 1.
All the 3s get relabeled as 1, and
that way the system knows that there's
exactly one object and all the pixels
with the 1s are the pixels from that
object, and it works just like that.
It works great.
Here's an example from that CT
cross-section I was showing you before,
and you can see that after some various
other operations that we'll talk about
in a minute, it's a, it's able to
label these different elements.
Okay.
And what's nice is those, those elements
have semantic meaning to the radiologist
who's, who's looking at these things.
You know, it's also useful for
if you have some clustering algorithms.
So here you are seeing,
just some clustering pixels, in a,
in a, in a beach sce, well,
it's no much of a beach, is it.
No.
Yuck.
Okay, it must be the Northwest.
No sand, just muck.
Sorry, Seattle.
And you see they're labeling
these different things
using connected components.